they're often these fads that come up
that their base more in virtue singling
than facts it's not about making the
world a better place folks it's about
saying that you're making your drink
taste like a number two pencil question
of the day before I get to the scam that
is paper straws thread what is your
opinion on paper straws have you had to
go to a restaurant request they're
strong they bring out that that's
sopping wet papers that you basically
have that you have to drink your gimlet
within three minutes otherwise it raced
like a number-two pencil
let me know what you think so let me
give you some context here for some
reason the entire environmental
discussion right now focuses on straws
yeah a lot of people don't really know
though some of the information -
environmental drink several reasons that
it's a skin right so this often happens
there's a fad within within the
environmental movement you could explain
to you why paper straws are just like
many hybrids I wonder where this came
from do you read an article I was very
well your little motivate winter The Keg
which is a Canadian chain and they
offered me a papers really and I'm the
work that I was servers regular what is
this is it lots of paper straw I can
make it a plastic straw please I said no
we can't I say what they said because
paper is better for the environment now
what I should say is nothing I would
like my steak medium-rare
instead too much about the soup so
they're often these fads that come up ad
that are meant to no this is one fad but
there are many feds we're gonna get a
dog there base more in virtue Singh
women's facts it's not about making the
world a better place folks it's about
saying that you're making your drink
tastes like a number-two pencil and the
paper straw thing looks good on its
surface a little taste like crap it's
not good yeah
so let's go through this a couple thing
that people need understand about paper
straws do you know that the whole reason
that we've shifted to paper straws oh
it's all base it's predicated on a
survey from a nine year old do you know
that oh my sir is really nine year old
and guess what that entirely fake
statistic used to push a fake narrative
that has now resulted and of course all
these multiple bands and legislative
actions but it's actually worse for the
environment
people saying how is it let me get let
me get to the nitty-gritty here
McDonald's just admitted that they can't
recycle their paper straws as they would
with their plastic ones oh geez
which by the way is made worse than your
reality when you realize that paper
straws require more electricity and
carbon emissions to produce and are
again less recyclable than the plastic
options oops
thank you my this isn't the first time
this has happened it comes off the heels
of a stack remember the styrofoam
fear-mongering the banned plastic cup
alternatives so we've gone from
styrofoam to plastic and we know that
baby are worse than plastic
well philosophy was worse in styrofoam
20% more carbon emissions 50% more
electricity to produce plastic cups over
styrofoam would you like a paper straw
with that hottest plastic cup no no I
want to say I watched ferngully always a
bpa-free you white privilege [ __ ]
turns out multiple studies not from a
nine-year-old actual studies found their
reusable bags actually have a lot worse
of an of an impact on the environment
than plastic yes you'd have to reuse an
organic cotton bag I wanna make sure let
me go to my my cheat sheet here organic
cotton x I'm wrapping I don't worry
using my bag twenty thousand times
twenty thousand times to make it even
with a plastic bag I think you would
have to be doing weekly grocery shopping
with your white your symbol of white
guilt for three hundred and eighty years
to break even worth it Stephen horse
people's just something a lot of people
don't think about right because the
vegan vegetarian before veganism owes I
think that's a new thing vegetarian but
I'm more of a brook so I'm a vegan
fast-food companies they used to they
used to use beef tallow
what does everything Tao are lard do you
know that audio wait you're
knowledgeable I don't you're
knowledgeable not so much okay
well these one be in there fries so all
of a sudden there was this a vegan
yeah edit area environmental lobby say
no you can't do that okay so we used
hydrogenated vegetable oils now which
have any idea think of it this way a lot
of us don't okay a ribeye look at the
fat content yeah the lard right that's
what you need you're talking about look
cooking with fat right
Lamarque look at your broccoli look at
your soybeans what are your corn look at
the fat content it's a third of the
slice of meat the cut of meat that
you're having versus zero grams of fat
usually in the vegetables vegetable this
is a very intensive and very unnatural
methods to extract vegetable oil which
is worse for your health and worse for
the environment by the way hit the
notification bell if you subscribed
already because the Scriptures don't
mean a whole lot
join Michael black under comes as much
Clemson we can shine a light on the book
that is listen it has about this and
Planned Parenthood let me roll so
another reason here a lot of people
think about this waste management
experts trust the problem here's a lot
of people own consider waste management
and why aren't we talking about it right
no one wants plastic in the oceans show
of hands everyone agrees here right now
I hate pollution oh I like pollution
sorry I need to come down you need to
take a puff but has vegetable in the
name Stephen I know I smoked at you
fasting it got bitter it tastes like
hydrogenated vegetable oil oh boy there
we go no one wants plastic in the oceans
it's it's predicated on something
there's a kernel of truth there people
want our environment to be cleaner yes
but just like the Paris agreement it
doesn't matter what we do because over
90% of the crap that ends up in the
ocean comes from ten rivers eight of
them are in Africa two of them are in
Asia bill Richman wonjun's named rich
and half asian larry bill Richman I want
a formal apology I'm doing my part it is
for one of them I'm using my doing my
purely responsibility plastic straws in
a Styrofoam cup what a plastic you jerk
none of them even come from our
continent think about that for a second
we could all completely eliminate all of
our carbon emissions and all of our
plastic use it wouldn't even make a dent
because first the contribute plastic the
ocean none of them are in North America
North America any portion any anywhere
in North America yes it's not them or
South America for that matter all right
that's actually that sirillium have you
been to the favelas in Brazil it was a
remarkably filthy I'm surprised
something doesn't go in the river there
but here's that liberals not they know
when we're not in their huddle it didn't
even solve the problem it's the litter
look at this it's literally this Vox
headline man
plastic straws won't save the ocean but
we should do it anyway no no no we
shouldn't do it anyway the too honest
for their own good here we only make up
what is it 15 percent of carbon
emissions yeah this isn't that people
need to understand if we again if we
think of this for a second if we stop
driving all of our SUVs right and this
is one thing - if you start driving a
hybrid car which has two giant non
recyclable batteries and doesn't really
get that much better mileage and a Ford
Fiesta that's worse for the environment
but let's assume that this is all
accurate to begin with we completely
eliminate 100% of our carbon emissions
and drive around our white guilt mobiles
and use the lithium-ion batteries I have
no I wouldn't make any difference so
enjoy your white guilt soda while you
destroy the environment for the rest of
us you hipster ass I don't know what
gluten is but if I found out what it was
I would hook it up to your veins like a
morphine drip I would be shoveling
mounds of gluten into your face right
long with the paper straws that you've
made me use we want to clean up we are
just not on board with the sweeping
government reforms that's the issue here
one wants our environment to be cleaner
yeah I understand it but then you go on
a second if it's completely illogical
this is worse for the environment we can
look at it statistically this comes from
a study from a nine-year-old and we know
that it is definitively worse for the
environment and nobody cares that's what
the headline says what are we doing then
all of a sudden Ted Turner proposing
China's one-child policy at the Cancun
climate summit I was there to Cheers
doesn't seem so outlandish by the way
the one-child policy your folks did it
first let me know what you think I just
think it's selfish of me I just really
hate paper straws hey there YouTube
viewer if you like this video click one
of these other videos playing in a box
subscribe hit the notification bell you
may be wondering why after this
outlandish video this is such a straight
end card that's because we've recently
learned that end cards actually
determine the YouTube algorithm as it
relates to controversy on a sliding
scale so we have a ello and it escalates
all the way to the word